يبدو ان ناخبون المسجلون في هذه
الانتخابات الادلاء باصواتهم في هذه
الانتخابات بعد مطابقه بطاقتهم الانتخابيه
والتاكد من انهم مسجلون في هذه
المراكز الانتخابيه عبر هذه الاجهزه
الالكترونيه التي تحوي جميع اسماء
الناخبين وكذلك
بصماتهم ومن ثم يتم تسليم الذين تم التاكد
من بطاقاتهم والانتخابيه
تسليمهم لبطاقات الاقتراع من اجل التصويت
في هذه الانتخابات التي يتنافس فيها 18
مرشحا لمنصب الرئاسه والاف المرشحين
لمقاعد مجلس الشيوخ وكذلك البرلمان
ونشرت ونشرت مئات الالاف من قوات الامن من
اجل تامين هذه الانتخابات التي هدد
المسلحون من غوكو حرام وكذلك
الانفصاليون في جنوب شرق نيجيريا بعرقله
هذه الانتخابات
وبسبب الاعيادات الكبيره للنفط هذه السنه
يتوقع
المرشحون الفائز من المرشحين في هذه
الانتخابات الاستفاده من هذه العائدات
وتحقيق ما احد به للناخبين في هذه
الانتخابات فضل عبد الرزاق
الجزيره
ابو جه